all right all right everyone still
coming into the venue uh we are about to
get started I'm incredibly excited to
see all of these people in front of me
uh my name is Misha I'm one of the
chairs and organizers of this conference
together with these people over here hi
everyone I'm Sophie Hi I'm Nikki and I'm
M I am incredibly excited for today and
for the days to come um but maybe let's
first have a look at how we got here in
the first place
oh I don't think we have the right
slides
here great started
conference all right while we get the
slides up I want to tell you a little
story of how we got here as P day to
Amsterdam in 2023 it actually started in
2016 not that far away from here also on
this side of the eye we were in a small
venue almost like a boat and we were
hoping for 200 people there um as you
can see we are moved to a little bit
bigger Venue at the moment um we have a
super nice venue here at the chrom out
Hall and uh we're really excited for
this conference to get
started yes so this is actually a
picture of what the venue was
before and the 200 people that we manage
to fit into one single room but it was a
success so we decided to do it again in
2017 18 2019 we were also part of the
organizing Committee in 2019 and we had
30 talks four tutorials two Keynotes and
over 300 attendees that we were very
proud of but today we're big we're back
and it's even bigger than ever so if you
look at the program for these days to
come we have 54 talks rather than the 30
we had before we have not four tutorials
but seven tutorials and instead of two
Keynotes we have five Keynotes and we
have a really nice list of
extracurricular such as Lightning talks
drinks by Kickstart AI a PB quiz Sprints
at CIA data hosted on Saturday and even
going back with the strob baffles we
have a real strob baffle clam this
afternoon at the Fue as well but maybe
the most important part is we have more
people than ever as well we have over
800 attendees so that's a lot bigger
than in
2019 and who are those attendees well as
you can see the majority of the people
are data scientists but you have a very
broad range of job titles we see we have
a lot of people in a lead role so
machine learning Engineers people from a
university and research as well and they
also have a lot of experience in data
science and machine learning as well but
one of the things that I'm very
interested in is to see uh who has been
to a pi data event before can you please
raise your hand oh I see a lot of hands
raised already also from all of the
committee here so that's nice um
who has never been to a pida event
before oh also still a lot of hands
raised so uh because of that I want to
tell you a little bit about what this
event is and the organization behind it
so I would like to invite Leah up on the
stage Clicker
thank you so much it is a pleasure and
an honor to be here um my name is Leah
silin I'm the executive director of num
focus and Pata is a numfocus educational
initiative um our mission is to support
open-source scientific Computing and
data science projects and to host
educational events so that we can make
sure that community of users and the
community the contributor Community
communities around those projects are
successful and and sustainable so Pi
data is um yeah an incredible part of
what we do and this is just a great
example of the communities that are
around the world and the growth of those
communities I was actually on that boat
um and worked with it the Fantastic
organizing team to put that together it
was right after the first Meetup started
I believe that first Meetup was held at
booking and we went on the boat a few
days later um for that first PID dat
event it was it was fantastic one of the
rooms swayed a little bit but that was
okay everyone got used to that and um it
was it was like I said it was um a great
event and everyone wanted to move
forward and to see the growth of the
community um yeah congratulations to
your community and thank you for
participating sharing your knowledge and
um yeah just contributing as a whole I
want to definitely thank everyone who
organized this um events don't happen um
by one single person or even a small
team it takes a group takes a community
and um this is amazing what we have um
what you've done and I want to give a
special thank you to the co organizers
Aden for their help and um their
partnership allowing pida Amsterdam to
increase in size and um truly go go big
this year this is amazing we're excited
about working with them and their
commitment to open source and look
forward to working with them in the
future I just want to tell you a little
bit about n Focus there were quite a few
hands that were raised that um were
first timers here so you may or may not
know about num Focus um our support to
projects is again supporting the
internal contributor Community as well
as the broader user community and we do
that by providing some essential program
support and services to projects we just
had our Summit for the first time in
Amsterdam um just wrapped up yesterday
it was a three-day Summit um there's
quite a handful of speakers that are
here today are actually um project
maintainers and leaders that were at the
summit um please if you're if you're um
out of talk and it's led by a project
maintainer contributor please reach out
and talk to them um we just had an
incredible time learning just trying to
have a better understanding of project
needs and how we can meet those needs
and allowing projects time to
collaborate and network together about
um you know what their challenges are
what their successes are we provide um
addition in addition to financial admin
and services a lot of legal support for
projects um helping them with
operational infrastructure and just
making sure that um we're helping in any
way we can for with project
sustainability we help with fundraising
um num Focus has its own small
development grant program um and we
provide grants on an annual basis
multiple times a year through that
program um also again helping with
fundraising so if you're employed
somewhere they're using nfocus projects
um please reach out have them get in
touch with us to learn about partnering
with us and how they can play a um play
a greater role in helping ensure the
sustainability of the projects and we
also I'd like to extend an invitation to
all of you to get involved to contribute
to projects we spend a lot of time
working with projects on new contributor
guidelines and being able to um Mark
areas where new contributors can start
whether that's um you know on specific
issues or documentation so please um
think about getting involved if you're
not contributing to an open source
project that you're using already um
like I said projects work really hard to
make that um to make it have an easy
entry point for new contributors so um
we'll be here at the numfocus table
we've got a few of our staff members
here we've got um Jim who is our um
events and resource director we'd be
happy to answer questions um any
questions you have as well as some Mina
and um who's ever at the num Focus table
so please um come introduce yourselves
we'd love to meet you and um yeah
looking forward to a fantastic event
thanks for being here and for your
participation y thank you Leah thanks so
much
[Music]
uh next slide next
slide
works okay welcome everyone for me as
well um I'm continuing with thank you
notes so the thank you to aan has been
mentioned as a
co-organizer but there is more um
there's three particular categories that
I would like to thank starting with the
sponsors in the money
green um specifically thanking our
Diamond sponsor Dexter who's been
involved with pida for the first time so
shout out to their to their trust in
that uh they have a really big Booth so
please hop by
check out the jobs that they have on our
job board online or um tomorrow end of
morning they have a talk on this main
stage if you want to find out more about
what they're working on of course also
our Platinum sponsors bubble hops workg
andabata shout out to them as well um
and the gold sponsors and the silver
sponsors that I will spare you listing
um but you will find them around in a
venue um I think the drinks were already
mentioned host by Kickstart AI another
nice data Community uh make sure to sign
up or check the link because we're full
now um but if people deregister Sports
will open up so this is also a call to
action if you don't come please
deregister um open source Sprint hoses
xabia we have these really nice projects
that you can mark your that you can mark
with your name uh please sign up as well
there's QR codes around the venue that
you can scan uh thanks for that
xavia then as a second category speakers
we wouldn't be able to do it without
speakers we had an overwhelming amount
of proposals this year over 250 that we
had to go through and we selected the
best uh and most diverse set of talks
for you so um yeah thank you for taking
the time to prepare two
speakers and then the golden pass for
the organizing committee we already got
a nice thank you from Leah but yeah one
of the stresses is all volunteer based
so shout out to all our volunteers here
around we have more than 35 of them
today all wearing the red so very
recognizable um but also the organizing
committee who is more than just the four
of us but some of us here on the front
row maybe make yourself known to the
audience and a Shameless moment of
self-promotion this is us a bit student
likee but really enjoying preparing this
event for you today uh and if you feel
like you also want to contribute to
something like this come and talk to us
we're very open to that um and if you
can't get enough of all the content that
you will see throughout these three days
follow us on Meetup because we also host
monthly
meetups now over to the
practicalities yes so hello everyone um
last thing for the Keynotes so over here
I have the floor plan um as you can see
there are three uh talk rooms F that's
the one main stage over here we have bar
not confused with the real
bar and we have Quicks um which is the
upstairs room over there you can take
the stairs in the
back then we also have the tutorial room
hello world the stairs are over there so
it's also an upstairs
room and then you've probably already
all seen it the registration desk just
near the
entrance so some uh practicalities um if
you have accessibility needs please make
yourself known at the registration desk
also if you're need of first aid um go
to that registration desk and if you
find something if you lost something
also yeah you get the gist now go to the
registration desk there will always be
someone
present some of the house rules um we
have a photographer being here all day
if you don't want to have a picture
taken you can uh change your lanyard for
a red one you can do that at the
registration
desk then the Wardrobe we have people
there but it's at your own risk
smoking is not allowed inside the
building and uh so please go on the side
of the
building and when there's a talk at the
main stage please be quiet we will also
put quiet signs when there's a session
going on
here and if a room is full uh full is
full the volunteers will put the full
room please don't
enter we also have a Wi-Fi the password
is awesome conference um the password is
also on the back of
your card we also have some super nice
goodies um you can pick up the goodies
after lunch today we have this um nice
toad bag and the nice
t-shirt then also importantly the code
of conduct so um these are our rules
always be kind to other s do not insult
behave professionally and remember that
harassment and sexist racist or
exclusionary drugs are not appropriate
or tolerated if there's a Code of
Conduct violation please make yourself
known to a volunteer or at the
registration desk um these things will
go directly to the code of conduct team
if you want to read the full code of
conduct please scan the code there are
also QR codes throughout the
venue then one my favorite Parts the
lightning talks lightning talks are here
today at
4:30 in case you don't know what a
lightning talk is it's your chance to
shine it's you can be on stage even
though you haven't um if you're not a
speaker and for five minutes do a talk
you can sign up on a flip chart at a n
Focus
booth and it's going to be really fun so
I would also really encourage you to
come and see the lightning talk
we also have a slack um QR cards are
throughout the venue you can try to scan
this one here you can uh talk to each
other talk to speakers if you have
questions after you've seen a talk you
want to meet someone then uh please
connect to each other on
slack and then and then with all the
practicalities actually out of the way
we can can really get this conference
started and it's my great pleasure to uh
to Welcome to the stage Vicky boyis he
uh we actually already asked her back in
2020 for the conference but
unfortunately couldn't make it then but
she's here now um you might know her
from her awesome blog uh with with great
articles like data science is different
now or is one of the organizers of the
very successful online Normcore ml
conference normon um or just general uh
posting on on Twitter please welcome to
the stage Vicky
[Music]
boyis